die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport ein stück von mir
für die linke ist es ein einschnitt
heute wählte ihre fraktion im bundestag
eine neue spitze und damit die
nachfolgerin von sahra wagenknecht die
50-jährige wollte nicht mehr kandidieren
auch aus gesundheitlichen gründen mit
ihr geht eine der prominentesten
vertreterinnen der linken partei intern
war sie umstritten ständig gab es
konflikte mit der parteispitze mit der
gründung ihrer bewegung aufstehen und
ihren äußerungen zur flüchtlingspolitik
spalte sie die partei hieß es zu ihrer
nachfolgerin wurde amira mohammed ali
gewählt sie wird künftig mit dietmar
bartsch die fraktion führen florian a da
sitzen sie noch einmal gemeinsam frauen
im fraktionssaal der linken am
nachmittag eher dietmar bartsch tritt
wieder an sie sahra wagenknecht wegen
eines burn outs als chefin ab
wagenknecht das zugpferd ihrer partei
kein anderer linken politiker so sehr
debatten geprägt wie sie kein anderer
aber auch intern so polarisiert das
interne gefüge zusammen zu halten oder
interne angriffe abzuwehren
das war nie meine stärke und ich habe
einfach gemerkt irgendwann hat es zu
viel von meiner zeit und meine kraft
auch in anspruch genommen nicht jeder in
der fraktion ist gleichermaßen
unglücklich über wagenknechts abgang von
der chef bühne
ich glaube dass wir eine chance haben
für einen aufbruch in der fraktion und
für eine führung die verstärkt
integriert dietmar bartsch wird mit
mageren 64 prozent wiedergewählt für
wagenknechts nachfolger hatten sich
gleich zwei politikerinnen beworben
caren lay seit zehn jahren im bundestag
und amira mohammed ali bundestags
neuling aus dem linken flügel geboren in
hamburg der vater aus ägypten
die rechtsanwältin bisher sprecherin für
verbraucher und tierschutz schafft im
zweiten wahlgang mit 52 prozent dem
strom
nach vorn ich glaube man muss in jeder
aufgabe reinwachsen das was uns
vorsitzen will kommt man nicht zur welt
sondern man muss natürlich da
reinwachsen
aber ich freue mich auch sehr darüber
dass ich von den erfahrungen meiner
fraktionskolleginnen und kollegen da
profitieren kann
zu diesen kolleginnen wird sie weiterhin
zählen sahra wagenknecht will präsent
bleiben im bundestag und öffentlichkeit
auch ohne amt gute nachrichten für alle
die eine betriebs rente beziehen ab
januar werden die beiträge für die
krankenkasse sinken auch das ist ein
teil des kompromisses der
bundesregierung zur grundrente derzeit
sind auf betriebsrenten im schnitt rund
15% kassenbeiträge fällig künftig werden
diese kosten durch freibeträge deutlich
gesenkt als annegret kramp karrenbauer
im juli verteidigungsministerin wurde da
sagte sie sie wolle die bundeswehr
wieder sichtbarer machen zum beispiel
mit öffentlichen gelöbnissen das
allererste fand genau vor 64 jahren
statt zur gründung der bundeswehr zum
jahrestag heute gelobten junge rekruten
an sechs orten öffentlich ihre treue zu
deutschland in mainz stralsund rotenburg
freiburg plön und vor dem reichstag in
berlin
von dort berichtet heike slansky
raus aus der kaserne rein in die
öffentlichkeit so will es die
verteidigungsministerin das feierliche
gelöbnis vor dem reichstag ein zeichen
sei dass für die verankerung der
bundeswehr in der gesellschaft die
bundeswehr ist ein unverzichtbarer teil
unserer gesellschaft sie kommt aus der
mitte der gesellschaft und sie gehört
dort auch hin
400 neu einberufene soldaten geloben
deutschland treu zu dienen auch die
gesellschaft sei gefordert so der
festredner
wer den frieden bewahren will bekommt
die nicht zum nulltarif wir als
gesellschaft müssen uns bewähren
indem wir uns nicht wegducken wo seines
deutschen beitrags zur sicherung des
friedens zur wahrung unserer werte
braucht indem wir unsere aufgaben
engagiert wahrnehmen die unser zu
unseren bündnisverpflichtungen erwachsen
wenn ich gegebenenfalls die bundeswehr
zum einsatz bringen will dann muss ich
sie auch entsprechend ausrüsten und
deswegen erwarten wir auch dass frau
kramp karrenbauer jetzt natürlich was
die materielle beschaffung anbelangt da
richtig gas gibt kleine proteste am
rande das ergebnis in berlin
hermetisch abgeriegelt daher nur halb
öffentlich kritik kommt von der linken
und den grünen
bei uns ist entscheidend verantwortung
nimmt ein land in vielerlei hinsicht auf
sich und da wäre es wichtig dass die
bundesrepublik deutschland sich stärker
um geflüchtete kümmern mehr
verantwortung im internationalen kampf
gegen die klimakrise und auch national
übernimmt
die bundeswehrrekruten jährlich
veranstalten die streitkräfte rund 150
gelöbnisse geht es nach kramp
karrenbauer künftig häufiger im
öffentlichen raum im rhein main gebiet
haben fahnder offenbar einen
islamistischen terroranschlag verhindert
sie nahmen drei mutmaßliche us anhänger
in offenbach fest einen deutschen
mazedonischer herkunft und zwei türken
die jungen männer sollen anschläge mit
bomben und schusswaffen geplant haben in
ihren wohnungen wurden chemische
substanzen gefunden mit denen
sprengstoff hergestellt werden kann
außerdem hatten die verdächtigen wohl
versucht schusswaffen über das internet
zu kaufen
im nahen osten macht ein neuer
gewaltausbruch zwischen israel und den
palästinensern sorgen aus dem
gazastreifen vier palästinenser seit dem
morgen dutzende raketen auf verschiedene
städte im süden israels
es ist ihre antwort auf eine
militäraktion wenige stunden zuvor
da hat der israels luftwaffe den führer
einer terror-organisation in gaza
getötet jetzt gilt in israel erhöhte
alarmbereitschaft nicola albrecht es ist
mitten in der nacht als die israelische
armee mit einem präzise ausgeführten
luftschlag das haus von bach avatar
einem befehlshaber der terror
organisation islamischer jihad
bombardiert er stirbt auch seine ehefrau
kommt ums leben
eine gezielte tötung empfohlen von der
israelischen armee angeordnet von
netanjahu und seinem kabinett
er hat viele angriffe auf israel geplant
und initiiert hunderte raketen auf die
gegend rund um den gazastreifen
abgefeuert das leiden der bürger
ignorieren wir nicht der islamische
dschihad spricht von einer
kriegserklärung auf gaza straßen hören
sie rache wir werden noch überraschungen
für die israelischen besatzer
bereithalten so etwas tolerieren wir
nicht seit den frühen morgenstunden
feuer nun kämpfer des islamischen jihad
fast unablässig raketen auf israel
häuser werden getroffen mehrere menschen
verletzt diese autofahrer entkommen nur
knapp dem einschlag für den
geschäftsführenden premier netanjahu
kommt diese entscheidung
für eine gezielte tötung samt
kalkulierter eskalation zur rechten zeit
denn er hat derzeit keine
regierungsmehrheit und ringt um sein
politisches überleben
in der vergangenheit wurde ihm oft der
vorwurf gemacht er habe in gaza nicht
hart genug durchgegriffen raketenalarm
auch in tel aviv
die schulen bleiben geschlossen den
bürgern wird geraten zu hause zu bleiben
und die israelische armee fliegt weiter
luftangriffe auf stellungen des
islamischen jihad in gaza mehrere
palästinenser sollen dabei getötet
worden sein
wir bleiben noch in israel
das land exportiert ja viele
agrarprodukte in die eu auch aus den
besetzten gebieten
jetzt hat der europäische gerichtshof
geurteilt wenn oliven avocados oder wein
etwa aus siedlungen im westjordanland
kommen muss ihre herkunft so auch
gekennzeichnet sein
israel spricht von einem
diskriminierenden urteil günther neufeld
hat die details die sonnigen hänge des
westjordanlands für die israelischen
siedler ein ertragreiches anbaugebiet
zwei drittel der ernte gehen in den
export
schon meine urahnen haben exakt in
dieser gegend wein angebaut wir haben
hier einen alten weinkeller von vor 2500
jahren
die männer israelis ihr wein
israelischer weine so sehen sie das doch
der europäische gerichtshof in luxemburg
sagt der wein komme aus einer
israelischen siedlung in einem besetzten
gebiet und genauso müsse das auch auf
dem etikett stehen
der zentralrat der juden findet das
urteil diskriminierend während bei
israel genau hingeschaut wird woher
exakt ein produkt stammt erleben wir
diese über korrektheit bei anderen
umstrittenen gebieten nicht vor 52
jahren eroberte israel unter anderem die
golanhöhen und das westjordanland
seither werden die gebiete von israel
kontrolliert gelten aber international
nicht als israelisches staatsgebiet
entsprechend müssten die produkte von
hier auch gekennzeichnet werden meinen
kritiker der siedlungspolitik nicht mal
die israelische regierung meint er
betrachte das westjordanland als
israelisches staatsgebiet im
israelischen laden in frankfurt am main
bleibt man entspannt der wein ist nach
eu-vorschrift gekennzeichnet mit der
etikettierung israelisches
siedlungsgebiet völlig unsinnig meint
der inhaber aber egal
umsatzeinbußen habe er deshalb nicht in
bolivien hat der zurückgetretene
präsident morales das land verlassen und
ist nach mexiko ins exil gegangen ein
foto auf twitter zeigt den früheren
staatschef auf dem flug ihm wurde in
mexiko asyl angeboten
morales kündigte aber an mit neuer kraft
zurückzukehren
die unruhen in bolivien halten an
militär und polizei sollen für ruhe
sorgen zu spät zu inkonsequent zu sehr
auf seiten der täter die aufarbeitung
von missbrauch in der kirche wird immer
wieder scharf kritisiert
die evangelische kirche in deutschland
hatte vor einem jahr einen elf punkte
plan dazu beschlossen und heute auf der
synode in dresden eine erste bilanz
gezogen und 770 opfer sind bislang
bekannt sie sollen in zukunft stärker
einbezogen werden
zum ersten mal hat auch eine betroffene
vor der synode gesprochen aus dresden
michael währungen
kerstin klaus hat schlimmes erdulden
müssen als sie 14 war wurde sie von
ihrem evangelischen jugend pfarrer
sexuell missbraucht jahre lang ging das
so weiter der täter wurde nie wirklich
belangt sie leidet unter den folgen bis
heute heute wirklich das ist noch immer
nicht gelingt betroffene in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen
das ist vielmehr um die täter und die
taten geht und nicht darum was
betroffene hier und heute brauchen in
dresden stellt sich die ekd vorwürfen
wie diesen spät klagen die betroffenen
770 missbrauchsopfer sind bisher bekannt
die dunkelziffer das wissen sie im saal
liegt weit höher
mit einem 11 punkte plan will die ekd
die aufarbeitung auf eine neue basis
stellen
im verlauf dieses lernprozesses ist uns
sehr eindrücklich klar geworden dass wir
zusammen mit den betroffenen eine
individuelle aufarbeitung leisten müssen
kerstin klaus die auch in betroffenen
beirat der bundesregierung sitzt reicht
das nicht bis heute setze die kirche
ihren null toleranz strategie gegen
täter und mitwisser nicht wirklich um
nein es ist nicht gut weil es diese
kirche ist die mich wie viele andere
immer wieder neu belastet weil sie nicht
handelt nicht angemessen taten und täter
schützende strukturen aufdeckt eine
pauschale entschädigung der betroffenen
lehnt die ekd ab setzt stattdessen auf
individuelle hilfen
jenseits solcher forderungen haben wir
uns entschieden eine freiwillige
leistung zu zahlen
die eben nicht diesen ganzen aufwendigen
und auch die betroffenen belastenden
rechts vorgang beinhaltet entschädigung
kann es deswegen nicht geben weil eine
solche schlimme erfahrung nicht mit geld
wettgemacht werden kann
kerstin klaus hält diese begründung für
zynisch eine entschädigung für die
lebenslangen folgen sexueller gewalt sei
mehr als an genossen noch zwei meldungen
die besonders für reisende interessant
sind es gibt entwarnung für die
lufthansa kunden weitere streiks der
flugbegleiter sind erstmal vom tisch der
konzern und die gewerkschaft ufo haben
sich auf ein schlichtungsverfahren
geeinigt ende vergangener woche waren
wegen eines 48-stündigen streiks mehr
als 1000 flüge aus
fallen und für thomas cook kunden ist
jetzt das offiziell was viele schon
befürchtet haben
der insolvente tourismuskonzern hat auch
alle reisen für 2020 abgesagt selbst
wenn diese bereits ganz oder teilweise
bezahlt sind
das betroffene kunden ihr geld in voller
höhe zurück bekommen ist
unwahrscheinlich die schadensmeldungen
übersteigen bei weitem die
versicherungssumme von 110 millionen
euro
bei wem und wann sie ansprüche in
welcher höhe geltend machen können
fragen und antworten zu dem fall thomas
cook haben wir auf heute de
zusammengefasst
die hitze in australien und damit die
buschfeuer saison beginnt gerade erst
trotzdem ist die lage schon dramatisch
ungewöhnlich lange dürre und starker
wind lassen immer neue feuer ausbrechen
entlang der ostküste fressen sich mehr
als 100 große brände durch die
ausgedörrten eukalyptuswälder jetzt
bedrohen sie den großraum sydney von
dort berichtet normen odenthal früh am
morgen kommen die flugzeuge
sie bringen brandschutz mittel den stoff
der das feuer aufhalten soll
sydneys vor ort rot aber trotzdem nicht
sicher
es brennt an allen ecken und enden immer
wieder vor katastrophaler gefahr wird
gewarnt im gesamten großraum situationen
ändern sich in kürzester zeit
unberechenbar die bedingung
es ist verflixt gefährlich es ist extrem
trocken diese dürre ist braucht so gut
wie nichts um ein feuer zu entzünden und
der wind peitscht immer wieder rein
unser kampf ist noch nicht vorbei
einsatz auf einsatz 3000 feuerwehrleute
ständig auf abruf 24 stunden ohne pause
die brände machen auch keine wo das
feuer durch zieht verwüstung und angst
die bleibt nach verdammt nah es das
feuer in den letzten tagen hier
hergekommen ein wohnwagen ist abgebrannt
die häuser sind gerade so stehen
geblieben die sorge jetzt dass es hier
immer noch glutnester geben könnte und
dass die flammen tatsächlich zurückkommt
es ist nicht sicher dass bleibt die
klare botschaft in vielen gebieten warnt
die feuerwehr eindringlich anwohner
sollten besser ab und so lange das noch
geht bevor sich fluchtwege schließen
bevor es zu spät ist
das ist mein zuhause aber was soll's ich
bin versichert und wenn es nicht anders
geht dann verliere ich lieber mein haus
als man leben
die feuerwalze kommt gnadenlos immer
näher
sie frisst sich durchs land new south
wales von der rekord dürre geplagt ist
eine allzu leichte beute
12.000 kilometer entfernt von sydney in
dubai findet gerade die leichtathletik
pfarrer wm-stadt norbert mit einem
hochmotivierten deutschen trio das kann
man wohl sagen heute goldmedaille nummer
vier und fünf kugelstoßerin begeht kuba
war wie erwartet erfolgreich und auch
sprinterin wenn susan siegte schon ihr
zweites wm-gold in dubai obwohl
irgendwann zusammen bereits über 200
meter gold gewonnen hat ist sie über die
100 meter nicht die alleinige favoritin
doch eine exzellente saison vorbereitung
soll auch in diesem rennen ihre früchte
tragen
nach ausgezeichneten 12,86 sekunden
macht sich die in südafrika geborene
28-jährige zur doppel-weltmeisterin über
die sprintstrecken ich habe gewusst ich
muss mir sehr sehr große folk die vierte
von insgesamt fünf deutschen
goldmedaillen hat bereits am vormittag
im kugelstoßen birgit kober gewonnen
für die münchnerin ist es bereits der
dritte titel bei weltmeisterschaften
starker start in london vorjahressieger
alexander zverev hat seine
eröffnungsspiel bei den atp finals
gewonnen
gegen den weltranglisten ersten rafael
nadal zum ersten mal in seiner karriere
triumphierte alexander zverev über den
19 maligen grand slam gewinner gute
returns gute aufschläge und eine ganz
starke vorhand waren der schlüssel zum
klaren zweisatzerfolg ist eine freude
gemacht gegen den besten auf der welt zu
spielen und das ist es heute gut
gelaufen
nach einer stunde und 23 minuten hatte
zverev die nummer eins der welt mit 6 2
und 6 4 besiegt nächster gegner morgen
der grieche stefanos city pass david
abraham bleibt kapitän der eintracht
trotz seiner attacke gegen freiburgs
trainer streich das bestätigte heute
frankfurts coach adi hütter aber haben
wir am sonntag in freiburg mit rot vom
platz gestellt worden
nach diesem rempler gegen streich dem
frankfurter kapitän droht jetzt eine
schwere strafe durch den dfb
von einer sperre von bis zu sechs
spielen ist die
sie versprechen für die spiele gegen
weißrussland und nordirland durch
bundestrainer löw bei den abschluss
vorbereitungen für die em qualifikation
wir werden beide spiele daheim gewinnen
so löw heute bei der ankunft der
mannschaft im düsseldorfer team-hotel
samstag das spiel gegen weißrussland in
mönchengladbach und am dienstag dann in
frankfurt gegen nordirland man schauen
wir mal versprochen ist versprochen
man sei optimistisch weniger schön das
wetter morgen wechselhaft mit regen und
schnee die details hat gleich aus den
internen marietta slomka spricht im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn mit
verteidigungsministerin annegret
kramp-karrenbauer wir sagen tschüss
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und sind morgen wieder da wenn sie mögen
auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
ein für beamte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter es gibt wenig änderungen und
im süden deutschlands schneit es sogar
noch ein bisschen weiter
das liegt daran dass wir mit einer
nordwestlichen strömung kühle luft
kriegen und aus dem süden kommt die
feuchtigkeit ansonsten die kaltluft die
rauscht weiter richtung mittelmeer und
hier entwickeln sich neue tiefs und es
bleibt dort in den nächsten tagen
ziemlich wechselhaft mit unwetter
schauen wir mal auf die nacht in der
südhälfte deutschlands weiterhin viele
wolken und es fällt schnee
nach osten hin liegt die
schneefallgrenze bei 600 metern im
nordwesten deutschlands ist auch regen
unterwegs bei temperaturen von minus 1
grad am alpenrand und sonst bei null bis
drei grad morgen im tagesverlauf
weiterer schnee vor allem im süden an
den alpen hier oberhalb von 1000 metern
gut 20 cm
im osten steigt die schneefallgrenze auf
700 meter ja unter im westen bilden sich
einige schauer das wird aber nicht viel
sein
dazu temperaturen zwischen 1 grad an den
alpen und 8 grad ganz im westen in den
nächsten tagen wird es erst einmal am
donnerstag noch trocken seien zwei bis
acht grad und ab freitag wird es vor
allem im süden wechselhaft bei 3 bis 13
grad
ein schöner abend